diseases carried by ticks are on the
rise some scientists predict this summer
could be the worst tick season in years
from May to July people will get more
tick bites than any other time
more than 30,000 cases of Lyme disease
are reported nationwide each year but
studies suggest the actual number is
closer to 300,000 ticks could also carry
other serious illnesses our dr. David
agus is in Los Angeles and joins us now
David good morning good morning
so we mentioned ticks we think Lyme
disease right away what are we looking
for this season well it's gonna be a big
one you know ticks follow certain
patterns and in this case warm winter -
winters in a row and also it's a record
eight corn harvest acorns were my seat
and my scary ticks so with mice happy
and running around we're gonna see more
ticks this year and we really have to
beware David both of my in-laws have
been diagnosed just recently with Lyme
disease this year it's a scary thing
it's it's not a comfortable thing it's
also very difficult to figure out
exactly what is wrong though right no
question about it it's a tough one you
know you're bitten by a tick sometimes
it could be a rash and then headache and
joint aches the real problem is is that
most of them or the one fda-approved
live test doesn't really turn positive
in most cases till four to six weeks
afterwards and not even in all cases
does it turn positive so it's really
hard to diagnosis so doctors are told if
you think Lyme disease treat for Lyme
disease so dr. agus fact or fiction is
it really a tick out there that creates
this allergy to eating red meat oh it's
the wildest thing is that it's really
come up over the last decade in getting
more common is there's a tick it first
bites a mouse or another rodent and then
a protein called alpha gal is there when
it injects you that protein is seen by
your immune system and creates an
allergy to meat so burgers and bait
burgers and bacon hard this holiday
season if you've bitten by this tick can
it be reversed or is it permanent
well in many cases it goes away on its
own medicines can treat it or in some
cases it does stay there but it's
certainly something that we were taken
by surprise and we're slowly learning
the mechanism and how to deal with it
so David kids
running around the yard today tomorrow
all summer here what are we to do do is
it is it is it bug spray with DEET no
question about it DEET works you know
they're very similar to mosquitoes ticks
smell you or sense your heat and that's
how they know where you are to grab on
and bite you wear long-sleeved clothing
try to cut the grass short so they ticks
can't hide there it's gonna be a big
season but David what if what if you see
it actually on your skin I know people
have found them before and aren't
certain how to actually remove it so how
to remove it is you take a tweezers you
put it at the base right near where the
head is and you slowly and consistently
pull upwards and try to get it out if
the head stuck it's almost like a
splinter and you got to dig it out but
the key is pull upwards and take it out
when your kids come in from playing
outside look them over look for ticks
and then put your clothes in the dryer
for 10 minutes and it'll kill the ticks
the heat of the dryer and lime is sort
of the most famous but there are other
diseases besides Lyme as well that takes
Kerry no question I mean there are more
and more of these diseases and some of
them can even be fatal and some of them
can have permanent neurologic deficits
so we're seeing diseases like Rocky
Mountain span of fever Powassan which is
the potential date a deadly one babby
see OSIS and lots of other ones so ticks
are a problem and this is going to be a
year where ticks really can see have an
impact on ours dr. David agus thank you
very much sir and happy fourth thank you
happy fourth guys it's a scary thing I
mean we're sure we're checking them not
just once a day but two or three times a
day all over the place in the garden
I've got everything I'm terrified as you
mentioned parents my mother got it as
well it's not just the kids that you
have to worry about yeah scary stuff